et pour en débattre nous sommes en
duplex depuis bruxelles avec dominique
que grease et avocat professeur de droit
européen dominique rizet bonsoir en face
de vous gilles casanova consultant en
stratégie et communication alors
messieurs les négociations donc
commencer chacun a affiché ses objectifs
on le disait aujourd'hui qui est en
position fort c'est ce que c'est l'or
aujourd'hui qui est en position de force
selon vous fois gilles casanova
commencer l'europe est un continent
la dame que nous avons entendu qui parle
comme la chancelière d'un empire
ursula von der leyen vous parlais tout à
fait exprime bien la façon dont d'abord
cet empire se considère comme l'europe
alors qu'il n'en est qu'une partie et
d'autre part comment il a une faiblesse
intrinsèque qui est qu'il n'est pas
démocratiquement le représentant d'un
peuple qui auraient choisi cette
personne cette dame comme représentante
de l'autre côté nous avons entendu boris
johnson qui lui vient d'être élu dans
des conditions claires transparentes sur
un programme et qui le met en oeuvre et
qui a montré d'ailleurs qu'il ne
cherchait pas à tirer vers le bas
l'europe déjà en faisant que son pays a
le smic le plus élevé d'europe et en
commençant à renationaliser les chemins
de fer ce qui ne va pas du tout dans la
logique de tirer vers le bas
le système par des coûts les plus bas
possibles qui est au contraire ce qui a
plutôt été la tendance de bruxelles donc
qui est en position de force
probablement celui qui peut s'appuyer
sur son peuple
parce qu'il l'a élu plutôt que celles
qui s'appuient sur des institutions qui
sont construites pour tenir à distance
des peuples qui aujourd'hui sont un peu
réticent dès qu'on leur pose une
question il répond non il y a d'ailleurs
une réponse on leur pose plus de
questions voilà qui évite alors
dominique griset on vient d'entendre
donc re gilles casanova parler de
l'europe comme un empire qui repose sur
des institutions est dit et qui donc ne
peut pas être plus fort que le royaume
uni avec un ministre élu par son peuple
votre réaction à ces propos de légines
casanova ma réaction serait plus brahim
plus pragmatique certainement que celle
que je viens d'entendre en fait je pense
que les négociations pour l'après ben
brik sites ont déjà commencé depuis
depuis fort longtemps et en tout cas
c'est ce que je m'entends dire par
certains négociateurs sectorielle au
niveau des autorités belges c'est ce que
je connais le mieux bien sûr et donc il
ya des tables de sujets qui ont déjà été
abordées qui font l'objet de discussions
assez avancé la majorité des sujets
d'après ce que l'on me dit ne pose pas
de problème et donc on pourront faire
l'objet d'un d'un accord assez
rapidement et puis il ya les sujets qui
fâchent
vous en avez parlé mais ces sujets qui
fâchent malheureusement ils ne sont pas
je crois dans un équilibre entre
un premier ministre anglais qui a été
quand même assez curieusement élus suite
à référendum à propos duquel on peut
quand même se poser quelques questions
je crois est quelqu'un qui n'aurait
aucune légitimité démocratique de
l'autre côté non nous sommes là dans une
discussion qui est avant tout économique
et qui par ailleurs met en place ou en
tout cas mais met en cause un certain
nombre d'autres d'autres éléments alors
j'irai que si on veut commencer par la
négociation économique mais nous sommes
c'est vrai en europe un bloc assez soudé
avec un certain nombre de libertés
auxquelles nous tenons et d'avancer au
point de vue de normes de qualité de
réflexion sur l'environnement sur la
protection des animaux toutes sortes de
choses qui tiennent malgré tout je
dirais d'un point de vue général à
l'essence de ce que sont les européens
malgré tout et d'un autre côté on a on a
quelqu'un qui effectivement entraîne
dans son sillage un peuple de 60
millions d'habitants mais qui se trouve
entre deux rives
il ne sait pas encore ce qu'on va lui
offrir des côtés de donald trump et il
doit déjà négocié avec l'autre côté de
la manche même si sa préférence va
classiquement pour les anglais du côté
du grand large
il ne sait pas encore à quoi s'en tenir
et donc il est obligé pour l'instant de
renier sa parole
soyons très clairs en étant très très
dur au départ de la négociation il doit
le faire parce qu'en réalité il ne sait
pas encore à quelle sauce donald trump
va le manger
gilles casamance que là
la discussion en ce qui concerne la
question de savoir qui al'avantage
aujourd'hui elle se place plutôt comme
ça et gilles casanova est ce que vous
vous rejoignez les propos qui vient
d'être peut-être dit justement sur le
fait que boris johnson est dans
l'incertitude il ne s'est pas finalement
vers qui se tourner sur cette question
des accords commayras un seul instant
d'abord le discours selon lequel
l'élection de boris johnson serai
curieuse se serait passé dans des
circonstances particulières si l'on veut
chercher sur le continent européen
une élection curieuse qui se serait
passé dans des circonstances
particulières nous pouvons regarder plus
près de nous et nous trouverons très
vite mais j'ai entendu un discours
idéologique purement idéologique qui
nous dit la négociation sera une
négociation économique puis aussitôt dit
les normes environnementales la
protection des animaux
tout cela c'est pas de l'économie c'est
de la vie c'est la société la question
de qui décide dans un pays ce n'est pas
de l'économie
c'est profondément la raison d'être des
civilisations et des sociétés peser sur
son destin et les nations elles sont le
produit de cela et donc la logique de
ceux de cette discussion c'est la
logique d'un pays d'une nation qui a
choisi de reprendre en main son propre
destin
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il a le
souhait ce pays de s'opposer au reste de
l'europe
il y a simplement des grands pour manque
on note dans l'histoire du continent
lorsque la france domine absolument tout
alors l'angleterre s'allie avec
l'allemagne et c'est la défaite de
napoléon à waterloo
sinon lorsque la france est dans la main
de l'allemagne de manière trop violente
occupés ou contrôlée d'une manière ou
d'une autre la grande-bretagne regarde
vers le grand large
on est dans cette situation et dans
cette situation on note que les
dirigeants allemands et leurs amis
français dans des conditions infiniment
moins difficile que la dernière fois ont
de nouveau perdu la bataille
d'angleterre parce que l'esprit d'empyr
qui anime les dirigeants allemands et
leurs amis français se heurte à ouffet
peut être parce que c'est une île que
l'idée nationale l'idée de la démocratie
à l'échelle d'une nation qui permet les
coopérations et l'internationalisme qui
entend bien le mot nation à l'intérieur
est quelque chose de plus pertinent
qu'un système qui fonctionne sur un mode
impérial c'est à dire où le sommet n'est
pas désigné par le peuple parce qu'il
n'ya pas un peuple parce qu'il ya des
peuples parce qu'ils n'ont pas les mêmes
débats parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
discussions les mêmes discussions et
qu'on a un système de prince électeur
qui ensuite se choisissent un dispositif
dans pire il ya là toute une discussion
sur la façon dont les sociétés humaines
peuvent collectivement faire avancer
leur destin et c'est tout un débat sur
la manière dont le continent européen
veut avancer alors les questions qui
sont posées
ce sont des questions qui songent pas en
2000 effectivement je prends part à pain
voilà je pense effectivement que ce que
vous avez précisé est assez juste
et il n'y a pas de contradiction chez
moi je pense que les différends
les européens sont parvenus à se forger
depuis la création de l'europe un
certain nombre de réflexes communs
d'idéologie commune de points sur
lesquels ils parviennent à avancer
ensemble et donc l'économie et ce dont
on discute mais ce qu'ils avancent
avant tout ce sont ces autres idées que
nous partageons en tant que robin est là
où
je suis particulièrement étonné par
votre disque ans et qu'on vous dit que
finalement nous sommes ce serait un
progrès de retrouver aujourd'hui un
retour à cet ancien régime des empires
que auquel vous faites référence est
dans le cadre duquel je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous l'angleterre se
retourne vers le grand large
vous voulez réagir phrase sympathie
entre l'allemagne et la france mais je
ne suis pas d'accord
si je peux je peux je peux juste je
voudrais juste terminée terminé gilles
casanova région en précisant que c'est
oui voilà tout ce que je veux dire c'est
que justement l'histoire de l'europe des
dernières années a permis de sortir de
cette logique mais bien sûr elle est
plus exigeante cette cette manière de
faire et je crois que on est parvenus
les progrès qui ont été faits montrent
qu'il y avait moyen de ne pas en
retourne et je n'irai pas au moyen-âge
mais pratiquement gelé ce que
l'angleterre a fait c'est de faire un
grand pas en arrière
je les ai à nouveau l'esprit dans pire
c'est celui qui domine bruxelles c'est
pas du tout le fric britannique
les britanniques veulent le retour du
pouvoir auprès du peuple britannique ça
pour lequel ils ont voté en votant une
brique site l'esprit dans pire c'est un
esprit dans lequel le sommet n'est pas
désigné par le peuple et je vous entends
parler des européens les européens ont
avancé les européens etc
c'est un discours qui couvre le champ
médiatique ce discours sur les européens
quand on parle sur lèze des européens
il s'agit environ 2000 bureaucrates
installé à bruxelles et leurs mandants
qui sont trois ou quatre fois supérieure
installé dans les divers pays de l'union
il s'agit pas du tout des peuples
l'union interrogés les peuples de
l'union comme les instituts de sondage
le fonds et vous vous rendez compte il
n'y a pas du tout cette unicité de vue
qu'il y as entre les technocrates qui
sont installés
à bruxelles et ça c'est un élément
absolument qui s'est tenue lundi les
appels à voter mais qui fonctionne de
manière unifiée parce qu'il s'est mis
d'accord autour d'un certain nombre de
points de vue qui sont des points de vue
politiques très cadrée et qui
considèrent que les populations elles ne
sont là que pour donner leur avis mais
pas pour décider
l'élément le plus clair a été juncker
qui dit aux ou grecs qui viennent de
voter contre un traité et pour élire de
nouveaux dirigeants
les élections servent à exprimer il a
dit aux italiens aussi exprimer le point
de vue d'un peuple mais la politique qui
est menée c'est celle des traités
dominique rizet vous vouliez réagir aux
propos de gilles casanova alors pas pas
ce dernier point là mais je crois que si
on a avancé justement en europe c'est
parce que de nouvelle génération comme
la mienne on ont passé les frontières
ont regardé quels étaient les cultures
des autres il n'était plus attachés à
leur glèbe et aux habitudes d'une
population locale ce que vous appelez
les peuples je pense que la grande
chance qu'on a aujourd'hui
chez nous c'est justement
l'interculturalité l'ouverture à
d'autres cultures et refermer les choses
en rayon ferment tout ça dans une
logique de peuples et de démocratie
locale
je pense que c'est c'est tellement
triste et c'est effectivement un tel
retour en arrière que qui est annoncée
effectivement par cette décision
anglaise qui est dangereuse parce
qu'elle peut en effet entraîner d'autres
d'autres pays à se retirer de cette
convention qui a été qui a été créée il
ya longtemps maintenant et qui feront
que l'europe se délitera très rapidement
c'est le risque que nous courons à ne
pas prendre le risque de
l'interculturalité c'est à dire de
regarder ailleurs que son propre nombril
le régime l'interdiction
et voilà ce qui est intéressant dans ce
que vous dites c'est que vous dites les
choses vous êtes franc et direct
ce que vous appelez l'europe ce ne sont
pas du tout des centaines de millions de
personnes
mais c'est une petite élite nomades et
plus multiculturaliste qui s'est formé
en tant que élite délibérément nomades
et multiculturaliste et qui a rompu avec
son peuple d'origine qu'elle regarde
avec le même mépris qu'un dirigeant
français de multinationales expliqué sur
une chaîne américaine qu'il venait d'un
petit pays dont personne ne parle la
langue et c'est exactement là le
problème
c'est à dire une oligarchie qui s'est
autonomisée des peuples dont elle
provient et qui prétend les diriger
indépendamment 2 dans l'histoire on a
constaté que ça ça avait du mal à
fonctionner et pour venir sur quelque
chose de plus pragmatique
moi j'ai entendu madame pécresse j'ai
entendu d'autres dirigeants européens
dire il faut faire payer aux
britanniques le prix fort pour le brésil
il faut que ce soit un exemple pour
chacun alors j'ai pensé que c'était
vraiment intelligent de dire ça et de le
faire ce serait encore plus intelligent
parce que si notre premier fournisseur
et l'allemagne notre premier client
c'est le royaume uni donc proposé de
traiter à la dure notre premier client
qui peut aller n'importe quand se
fournir n'importe où ailleurs c'est
vraiment un choix réfléchi et est posée
est raisonnable dominique des risées est
ce que vous partagez cet avis comme quoi
il y aurait au fond
cette pensée de faire payer au royaume
uni son départ de l'union européenne
selon vous est-ce qu'elle existe cette
pensée là alors je suis certain qu'elle
existe chez certaines personnes
mais par contre dans le cadre des
accords commerciaux par exemple il y à
une logique aux actions alors dans le
corps des avocats des accords
commerciaux
l'essentiel c'est effectivement de ne
pas créer un pont commerciales entre les
etats-unis et les pays tiers et l'europe
par lequel nous puissions nous faire
assez facilement envahir de produits que
nous ne souhaitons pas par ailleurs voir
rentrer sur notre territoire
communautaire parce que effectivement on
a mis des normes de qualité on a mis
d'énormes même au niveau social même si
elles ne sont si elles sont très loin
d'être parfaite et qu'on n'a pas envie
que ces produits rentrer de manière
indirecte donc effectivement face à
cette incertitude on veut parler au
départ à savoir comment les choses
vont-elles se passer entre les états
unis et l'angleterre
on doit nécessairement être extrêmement
prudent on doit et c'est logique
exiger le respect des normes de qualité
des normes techniques que nous avons mis
en place avec beaucoup de peine et qui
pour beaucoup de produits permettent que
nous ayons en europe des produits de
meilleure qualité que ce soit dans
l'agricole que ce soit aussi dans la
construction industrielle les joueurs
tout ce que vous pouvez imaginer
il ne faut pas que l'angleterre soit un
sas pour que tous les produits de
moindre qualité ayant été construits
avec des normes sociales moins favorable
puisse rentrer en europe et donc dans
cette mesure l'un il est nécessaire qu
on ait une négociation sérieuse sévère
avec
l'angleterre est ce qui s'est passé avec
la nouvelle déclaration du premier
ministre
c'était comme un pied de nez c'est à
dire que dans le cadre des négociations
avant breakes site
on nous a expliqué que le but n'était
pas de jouer avec les pieds de l'europe
que le but n'était pas de diminuer ces
normes d'ailleurs les normands delhaize
était tout à fait excellentes et que par
conséquent tout ce qu'on veut c'est
avoir le libre accès pour les produits
mais ne pas obéir aux autres normes mais
si on négocie de par ailleurs des
accords de libre échange où les qualités
la question de la manière dont les
poulets sont traités aux états unis
n'est pas réglé eh bien on a alors
insisté alors il va effectivement
permettre l'entrée en europe de produits
que nous ne souhaitons pas avoir alors
2000 grise être sévère dans la
négociation gilles casanova il nous
reste quelques minutes je vous propose
d'écouter michel barnier il était
présent à bruxelles vous réagir après
juste après michel barnier négociateur
en chef de l'union européenne donc pour
le break site a déclaré qu'il était prêt
à proposer un accord commercial très
ambitieux sans droits de douane ni de
quotas sur toutes les marchandises vous
nous direz ce que vous en pensez après
on écoute enfin un seul prêt à proposer
un accord commercial très ambitieux
comme plisson preuve de ce partenariat
il sans droits de douane ni quota sur
toutes les marchandises en transit entre
marc génis de 450 millions de personnes
agri nous devons maintenant nous mettre
d'accord sur des garanties spécifiques
et efficace pour assurer l'égalité des
chances à long terme cela signifie un
mécanisme permettant de maintenir les
normes élevées dont nous disposons
matière sociale environnementale
climatique puisqu'elle est dette d'état
et dont leur évolution future
tout d un india futur développe
alors il vous reste une minute chacun
messieurs pour réagir aux propos de
michel barnier pour conclure gilles
casanova c'est le moment de comédie et
fantaisie on nous dit que l'angleterre
va faire entrer des eaux des
marchandises terrible qui viennent des
états unis
mais on est en train à bruxelles de
négocier avec les états unis un type 2
traités qui permettra bien pire que ce
que l'angleterre ne fera jamais on nous
parle de normes sociales qui ne sont pas
à la hauteur et l'angleterre pourrait
faire entrer des produits et des normes
sociales qui ne sont pas à la hauteur
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait avec la chine
que font les seize pays de l'union
européenne qui ont négocié avec la chine
et que fait la commission qui elle-même
accepte de chine des produits qui ont
des normes sociales sans commune mesure
avec les nôtres c'est une comédie une
comédie pour gilles casanova dominent
égalisé pour conclure alors je pense pas
devoir répliquer à ce qu'il dit je pense
que c'est assez inexact mais je dirais
que healy a en fait deux choses
différentes
les pour en ce qui concerne les produits
dont je partage entièrement de la pensée
de nos cieux barnier je dirais qu'en ce
qui concerne les produits qui sont
produits en angleterre je ne pense pas
que nous ayons de grandes difficultés de
ce côté-là ça je ne n'ai pas dit tout à
l'heure je pense qu'effectivement il y a
des règles en angleterre qui ne seront
pas revus à la baisse
après le mexique encore une fois notre
problème majeur c'est de ne pas
permettre l'entrée indirecte de produits
que nous ne voulons pas voir chez nous
et que contrairement à ce que dit
monsieur casanova
nous ne sommes pas prêts à laisser
rentrer dans le cadre des grands accords
de libre échange il ya bien sûr des
exceptions et des contrôles mais et des
contrôles par rapport à nos normes
c'est bien évident merci beaucoup
dominique qui grise est je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat professeur de droit
européen vous des batié ce soir avec
gilles casanova consultant stratégique
des communications merci at elle a tous
les deux voilà c'est la fin